en fait d'un robot voilà c'est une
machine qu'on force à faire un travail
qui va être capable de le faire tout
seul
justement alors nous aujourd'hui on va
fabriquer ce petit robot capable
d'avancer en ligne droite et d'éviter
les obstacles
ce robot paraît simple mais cette
construction demande quand même un peu
de pratique ses trois enfants sont là
pour apprendre les meilleures bosse j'ai
fait d'ateliers les petits chercheurs
agissent en boutique
et puis du coup je viens on dit essayer
ça permet de rire savoir ce qui se passe
dans un an vous dénuder les fils
assemblée est soudé les composants
chaque étape est réalisé par les
participants mais parfois avec un peu
dead antoinette animateur pour l'atelier
des sciences son objectif initier les
plus jeunes à la technologie de manière
ludique on baigne dans cet univers mais
c'est pas pour autant qu'on le comprend
justement c'est on a on est on a une
approche donc on a toutes ces choses
autour de nous mais on les comprend pas
forcément est justement voilà l'atelier
des sciences aide aussi enfin ces petits
ateliers servent aussi à ça justement à
faire comprendre justement l'univers
scientifique qui nous entoure des
ateliers gratuits sur réservation
prochaine séance le 13 mai sur le thème
mécanismes et engrenages